[Musique]
mais moi je sais où c'est
devenir le nouvel empereur de Chine
dans le marbre de l'histoire j'adore
quand tu dis ça j'adore à tous
bien pourquoi faut-il toujours qu'on
vient nous demander de l'aide à nous non
mais non moi je suis d'accord j'ai rien
en ce moment
je t'arrête la princesse est loin on va
se marier et tu sais quoi Obélix tu
seras mon témoin mais c'est pas vrai il
est en train de lui parler en train de
relancer
vous faites quoi là
je vais vous montrer comment on se
bagarre en Chine
oh si je suis amoureux
de cœur dans cette aventure
[Musique]
[Rires]
petit scarabée c'est très facile vous
vous êtes aveugle
jamais qu'un homme ne voit pas parce
qu'il est important et c'est là tu l'as
vu venir voilà